Welcome to SmartLess with Jason Bateman, Sean Hayes, and me, Will Arnett. Each week, one of us brings on a special guest and surprises the other two. They don't know who the guest is, which makes it fun. And then we laugh and we get a little less smart less. So I guess more smarter. More smarter. We should have named it more smarter. Anyway, come take a ride on the SmartLess train.
欢迎收听由杰森·贝特曼、西恩·海耶斯和我威尔·阿奈特主持的《SmartLess》。每周，我们中的一个人会带一位特别的嘉宾来给另外两人一个惊喜。他们不知道嘉宾是谁，这很有趣。然后我们大笑，变得不那么愚蠢了。所以我想是变得更聪明了。更聪明。我们应该把它命名为更聪明。总之，快来登上“SmartLess”号列车吧。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Jason, do you enjoy this time off? Let me answer for him. No. No, I do.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。杰森，你喜欢这段假期吗？我来替他回答。不。不，我很喜欢。
I do. I enjoy it to a level I'm not feeling proud of. I'm a little, I feel a little guilty like I could be or should be doing something more because there are so many people that are having trouble throughout it. It is not a, not a happier, healthy time globally, but I do have to say selfishly I am enjoying spending the time with my kids that I can't usually, as I'm sure a lot of people are, but I don't know. I would like to say I'm enjoying my time with you two very much.
我很喜欢。我喜欢的程度连我自己都觉得有点不好意思。我有点，我感到有点内疚，觉得我本可以或者应该做更多的事情，因为在这期间有那么多人遇到困难。在全球范围内，这并不是一个快乐、健康的时期，但我不得不自私地说，我很享受和孩子们在一起的时光，这是我平时做不到的，我相信很多人也是这样，但我不知道。我很想说我很享受和你们两个在一起的时光。
You would like to say it, but you won't. I'm sorry. Well, do you want, are we on, we're on a meal break? Should we ask our guests to wait a little? Says you. You came on stuffing your face yesterday. Yes. Well, it was a little, it was a energy bar, energy bar.
你想说，但你不会。对不起。好吧，你想，我们在休息吃饭吗？我们应该让我们的嘉宾等一会儿吗？你说得对。你昨天来的时候也是狼吞虎咽的。是的。好吧，那是一点，能量棒，能量棒。
And when does that kick in? It wasn't a Reese's Sorry Nuts. When does that kick in, he said? Hilarious. That's good. He took it yesterday and all of it. It's so good. And it's so true.
这东西什么时候起效？那不是 Reese's 坚果零食。他刚才说那东西什么时候起效？太搞笑了。真不错。他昨天把那些全吃光了。太棒了。而且太真实了。
Yeah. I'm going to bring the energy this time. I'm going to really bring the noise on this. This is going to be one of my best podcast sessions. It's been fun watching you, Jason, on this road to go fuck yourself, you know. Okay. Some, some guests that we bring on do not need a long introduction, but today I've carved out 20 minutes now.
是的。这次我要拿出活力来。我这次一定要大肆宣传一下。这将是我最棒的播客节目之一。看你在自取灭亡的路上走着，杰森，挺有意思的，你知道的。好吧。我们请来的一些嘉宾不需要长篇大论的介绍，但今天我已经腾出了20分钟。
But today we have another Canadian actor on today. So well, you can help us translate maybe I love how close Jason's fake laugh is to his real laugh. Right. That was good. Energy. This fella has had more success than all three of us combined basically. It's not hard.
但今天我们请到了另一位加拿大演员。所以，也许你可以帮我们翻译一下。我喜欢杰森的假笑和真笑是多么的相似。对。刚才那表现不错。很有活力。这家伙基本上比我们三个加起来还要成功。这并不难。
He's an actor, director, producer, writer, entrepreneur, philanthropist, and pretty sure he's my personal driver too. His name is synonymous with Jed Apatow and vice versa. My guest today is the highly intelligent Seth Rogen. Hi guys. Hi guys. There he is. Uh-oh.
他是一位演员、导演、制片人、编剧、企业家、慈善家，而且我确信他也是我的私人司机。他的名字是贾德·阿帕图的代名词，反之亦然。我今天的嘉宾是才华横溢的塞斯·罗根。大家好。大家好。他来了。哦，不。
Seth. What's up? Seth. Seth's wearing his grandfather's sweater today. Exactly. This takes our, our guest list into a different, a different area here. Yeah. I didn't, I haven't Googled who, who has been, I assumed I was like right in the pocket
塞斯。怎么了？塞斯。塞斯今天穿着他祖父的毛衣。没错。这把我们的嘉宾名单带到了一个不同的领域。是的。我没有，我没有谷歌搜索过，谁，是谁，我以为我正好切中了
of who you are. Yeah. Well, it's taking it down a little bit. Yeah. No, Seth. Very nice of you to join us. Yeah. Oh, look who it is.
你们的圈子。是的。好吧，这把档次稍微拉低了一点。是的。不，塞斯。很高兴你能加入我们。是的。哦，瞧瞧是谁。
Seth, eh? Glad to be here. Yeah. How about I didn't know you were Canadian? You didn't know I was Canadian? No. By the way, I didn't either. What?
塞斯，是吗？很高兴来到这里。是的。我怎么不知道你是加拿大人？你不知道我是加拿大人？不知道。顺便说一句，我也不知道。什么？
I just thought all Jewish people are American. Yeah, exactly. It's, I'm complimented when people don't assume I'm Jewish. I'm not complimented when people don't assume I'm Jewish either. I didn't know you were Jewish either. See that? I think every Jew likes it when that happens a little bit. I don't really think about religion or place of origin.
我以为所有犹太人都是美国人。是的，没错。当人们不认为我是犹太人时，我会感到受了恭维。当人们不认为我是犹太人时，我不会感到受恭维。我也不知道你是犹太人。看到了吗？我想每个犹太人遇到这种事时都会有点暗爽。我其实并不怎么考虑宗教或出生地。
You should because they're both highly influential as to why people are who they are. Now what about that? Do you agree with this intro element of synonymous with Judd Apatow and Judd Apatow as a synonymist? I don't, I don't, I don't think so anymore, right? I mean, maybe when you got, you guys both kind of started around this, was it Freaks and Geeks that you guys both, uh-huh, that's when we first met in 1998, so I guess it was. Such a great show. Yeah, such a great show.
你应该考虑，因为这两者对人们形成今天的性格都有着极大的影响。现在这个呢？你同意关于“与贾德·阿帕图齐名”以及贾德·阿帕图是……的同义词的这个介绍吗？我，我，我不再这么认为了，对吧？我是说，也许当你们，你们俩基本上都是在这个时期开始的，是《怪胎与书呆子》让你们两个，嗯哼，那是我们1998年第一次见面，所以我想是的。真是一部好剧。是的，真是一部好剧。
You both have career, you have, you have a career enough for seven people as does he. He really does. Seth, did you write on Freaks and Geeks as well? No, I was always trying to and I was like, I would submit scenes and things like that and episode ideas, but I, I, yeah, I, it got- It wasn't till undeclared? Yeah, I feel like if maybe Freaks and Geeks went a second season, I had a chance of being hired as a writer, but then, yeah, I got hired on undeclared as well.
你们两个的职业生涯，你的职业生涯足够七个人忙的，他也是。确实如此。塞斯，你也参与了《怪胎与书呆子》的编剧吗？没有，我一直在尝试，我会提交剧本场景之类的内容和剧集创意，但，但，是的，它——直到《无斯可归》？对，我觉得如果《怪胎与书呆子》有第二季的话，我还有机会被聘为编剧，但后来，是的，我也被《无斯可归》录用了。
And how old are you on Freaks and Geeks? I was like 16 and 17 when we did Freaks and Geeks. That's amazing. How old are you now? I'm 37. Isn't it weird how we, I start, I start forgetting. 38, 38? I'm 38.
拍《怪胎与书呆子》的时候你多大？我们拍《怪胎与书呆子》的时候我大概16、17岁。太惊人了。你现在多大？我37岁。我们开始，开始健忘，这不是很奇怪吗？38，38？我38岁。
You start forgetting. I literally, I'm 38. Yeah. I had to do actual math to figure that out. Wait, so, and I read somewhere that you, when you were 16 doing Freaks and Geeks, that you were kind of the breadwinner of the family and you helped support the family. Is that any of that true? Yes.
你开始健忘。我真的，我38岁。是的。我得做个实际的数学计算才能算出来。等等，所以，我看到有报道说，你16岁拍《怪胎与书呆子》的时候，你算是家里的顶梁柱，你帮着养家糊口。这些都是真的吗？是的。
When your parents are socialist Jews, it doesn't take much to hit that bar. Can I go deep on that? Sure. Go for it. I have a, I had a similar childhood. Yeah. Now, were your parents your manager as well? No, not at all.
当你的父母是社会主义犹太人时，达到这个标准并不需要费多大劲。我能深入聊聊这个吗？当然。尽管问。我有一个，我有一个类似的童年。是的。现在，你的父母也是你的经纪人吗？不，完全不是。
Thank God. They like had no, no, they knew that would be a weird dynamic, I think. Yeah, it is a weird dynamic and this is about to get really dark and sad with Jason. Is it safe to cry on a podcast? Exactly. No, no, no. Wait, but you are contributing some cash into the family pot? Yes, very much so.
谢天谢地。他们大概觉得，没有，没有，他们知道那会是一种奇怪的动态，我想。是的，这确实是一种奇怪的动态，而且杰森的话题马上要变得非常黑暗和悲伤了。在播客里哭安全吗？没错。不，不，不。等等，但你确实往家庭共同的钱罐里贡献了一些现金？是的，非常多。
It was kind of like a convergence, like the timing was like coincidental in some way where like I was about to graduate, well, like be the age when I, one would graduate high school, although I was not going to graduate high school. I didn't do it either. Yeah, like, and we lived in a house that my parents like couldn't afford anymore, but my sister had gone to college and I was moving out. So like it's, and neither of them, and they had both lost their jobs around that time, totally coincidentally.
这有点像是一种汇聚，就像时机在某种程度上是巧合一样，比如我快要毕业了，或者说到了一个人该高中毕业的年龄，尽管我并没有高中毕业。我也没毕业。是的，就像，我们住在一栋我父母再也负担不起的房子里，但我姐姐已经上大学了，我也要搬出去了。所以，而且他们两个都没有，而且他们俩大约在那个时候都失业了，完全是巧合。
Both your parents had? Yes. And so we, they were like, I guess if I hadn't gotten a job, they would have moved into a small apartment with me somewhere in Vancouver. But then I got cast on Freaks and Geeks from Vancouver and because they were both unemployed and we were selling our house anyway, we all moved to LA. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, so hold the phone.
你父母俩都失业了？是的。所以他们当时想，如果我没有找到工作的话，他们就会和我一起搬到温哥华的某个小公寓里。但后来我从温哥华被选角参演了《怪胎与书呆子》，因为他们俩都失业了，而且我们反正也要卖房子，我们就一起搬到了洛杉矶。等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，所以别挂电话。
So Freaks and Geeks is casting, you go to a casting director or put yourself on tape out of Vancouver? Yeah. That was what's weird. It was the second audition I ever went on. Like I did stand up comedy for years from when I was like 13. And then I. Where'd you get the balls to do that?
所以《怪胎与书呆子》在选角，你是去见选角导演还是在温哥华录制了试镜磁带？是的。奇怪的是，那是我参加过的第二次试镜。我从大约13岁开始说单口喜剧，持续了好几年。然后我。你哪来的胆子做那个？
That's at a young age. I think when you're 13, you don't, you just don't give, like I look back, you just, you literally have no balls. So it just, it just like, it doesn't fucking matter. And you're trapped yet. Yeah. I didn't give a shit. Like I look back and was so fearless in comparison to how much I overthink everything now.
那是在很小的时候。我想当你13岁的时候，你不会，你根本不在乎，如今回想起来，你真的完全没有怯场。所以它只是，只是，根本无所谓。而且你当时还被困住了。是的。我根本不在乎。如回想起来，相比于现在我对每件事都想得太多，我当时是如此的无所畏惧。
But I, yeah, I did stand up and then I got an agent through stand up and Freaks and Geeks Judd to his amazing, you know, credit has always been like great with casting especially. And he did, they searched in every major city in North America, like they had open casting calls in every in Chicago and Toronto and Boston and Vancouver and New York. And, and, and I didn't go into the open casting call, but I had like a scheduled audition like the morning of the open casting call. Wow. Yeah.
但我，是的，我做了单口喜剧，然后我通过单口喜剧找到了经纪人，《怪胎与书呆子》的贾德非常了不起，你知道，他一直以来在选角方面都非常出色。他们搜索了北美每一个主要城市，他们在芝加哥、多伦多、波士顿、温哥华和纽约都进行了公开试镜。而且，而且，我没有去参加公开试镜，但我有一个预约好的试镜，就在公开试镜的当天早上。哇。是的。
So when you started contributing as significantly as you did to the family pot and Jason obviously wants to get back to you. Was there interest on the payback? Exactly. Did you also buy a gun in order to murder both your parents? How influence were the Menendez brothers in your life overall? Did you notice that it changed the dynamic between child and parent as far as that natural, and I would say healthy dynamic of deference, right?
所以，当你开始为家庭经济做出如此重大的贡献时，杰森显然想回到这个话题。有关于回报的利息吗？没错。你有没有为了谋杀双亲而买枪？门endez兄弟在你的整体生活中受到的影响有多大？你有没有注意到它改变了孩子和父母之间的动态关系，就那种自然的、我会说是健康的顺从动态而言，对吧？
Where I, I look up to you parent, you can do things that I could never do like pay a mortgage and all that. Did you find an equaling in the dynamic there that was actually not healthy, not helpful? In other words, it became more of a peer relationship. I'm not projecting at all. No, exactly. I think what's interesting is my parents like, my dad especially like never even remotely subscribed to the idea that it was his responsibility to financially carry the family in any way
比如我，我仰慕你，父母，你能做我永远做不到的事情，比如付房贷等等那一切。你有没有发现那里的动态中有一种趋于平等的关系，实际上是不健康的、无益的？换句话说，它变得更像是一种同龄人关系。我完全没有在投射。不，完全没有。我觉得有趣的是，我的父母，尤其是我的爸爸，从来没有哪怕一点点认同过“在经济上独自挑起家庭重担是他的责任”这种想法，
shape or form. Like it was, he just like, yeah, like it was just like, he's like, I don't like working anymore. Like why should I like, you know, and, and he's like, I don't have any special skills. Like why, like, why would this fall on me? Like honey, Seth's got money. Exactly. And I actually like, it actually started, it started very early because like my family
无论以何种形式或方式。就像，他只是，是的，就像，他就觉得，他觉得：我再也不想工作了。像，我凭什么要喜欢，你知道的，而且，而且他觉得：我没有什么特殊技能。像，为什么，为什么这种事要落在我头上？就像：亲爱的，塞斯有钱。没错。而且我其实，这其实很早就开始了，因为我的家庭
never had a lot of money and we grew up on the east side of Vancouver, which at the time, especially was like not a fantastic neighborhood to grow up in. And I didn't know though, honestly, like, but, and it was like, I remember I had a bar mitzvah when I was 13 and I got like $7,000 in bar mitzvah gifts. Dad said, I'll take that. Yeah, exactly. And years, they were like, we're just going to keep this in like a fund and you'll get it when you're like, you know, 70 or some shit.
从来没有很多钱，我们在温哥华东区长大，当时特别是，那不是一个非常棒的成长社区。不过老实说，我当时并不知道，但是，就像，我记得我13岁时举行了成年礼，我收到了大约7000美元的成年礼礼物。爸爸说，这钱我收下了。是的，没错。几年后，他们说，我们只是把这笔钱放在一个基金里，等你到了，你知道的，70岁左右或者别的什么岁数时，你就能拿到了。
And then when I was like 17, I was like, do I get my bar mitzvah money? And they're like, you know, that washer and dryer that had been cleaning your clothes for the last five years, that's your bar mitzvah money, congratulations. And I was like, yeah, I mean, I got it ultimately, like it kind of made sense. So it wasn't a huge leap, like to Jason's point, it wasn't a huge change in the dynamic in the parent child. No, if anything, if we want to get like, you know, if we want to go to therapy about it, I think probably a large part of the motivation I had from such a young age to be successful
然后当我17岁的时候，我就问：我能拿到我的成年礼钱吗？他们说：你知道过去五年里一直帮你洗衣服的那台洗衣机和烘干机吗？那就是你的成年礼钱，恭喜。然后我就想，好吧，我的意思是，我最终还是拿到了，这某种程度上说得通。所以这不是一个巨大的飞跃，就像杰森所说的那样，它并没有给父母与子女的动态关系带来巨大的改变。不，如果要说的话，如果我们想就此进行心理治疗的话，我想我在如此年轻的时候就有强烈的成功动机，很大一部分原因可能是
was because I did not have a lot of faith that my parents would be the ones to financially support me throughout my life. Yeah. So I was like, I better make a lot of money, you know. And if you're like me, you also felt an early blast of responsibility and capability. And it was, I actually took it as like a positive thing. I felt very confident that I could like go out there and make money and support not only myself, but maybe even a family at an early age.
因为我对父母能够在我的一生中为我提供经济支持并没有抱太大的信心。是的。所以我当时想，我最好多赚点钱，你知道的。如果你像我一样，你也会感受到责任感和能力的早期爆发。而且，我其实把它当成了一件积极的事情。我感到非常自信，觉得自己可以走出去赚钱，在很小的时候不仅能养活自己，甚至还能养活一个家庭。
So I took it as a positive. But in hindsight, there were elements of it that probably weren't fantastically healthy. But no, for sure. And it definitely like few, I'm sure if my parents didn't spend my bar mitzvah money on a washer and dryer, I would not be a successful comedian today. So, but what's funny about that is, so your folks, what were they like? Were they ex hippies? How did they get to the place where they were living that way?
所以我把它当成了一件积极的事。但事后回想起来，其中确实有一些元素可能并不是非常健康。不过，不，肯定的。而且绝对像，我敢肯定，如果我的父母没有把我的成年礼钱花在洗衣机和烘干机上，我今天就不会成为一个成功的喜剧演员。所以，但有趣的是，你的父母，他们是什么样的人？他们是前嬉皮士吗？他们是怎么过上那种生活方式的？
They met on a kibbutz in Israel, literally. So like they, my dad would have never left. It was like, for my mom, it was like a fun thing to do in her early 20s for a couple of years. And for my dad, it was like, I'm going to live my life on a kibbutz in Israel. And then they fell in love and she convinced him to move to Vancouver, which compared to Newark, New Jersey is a kibbutz in Israel in a lot of ways, which is where my dad is from.
他们真的是在以色列的一个基布兹（集体农庄）相遇的。所以，就像，我爸爸绝对不会离开。但对妈妈来说，这就像是她在20出头时觉得好玩、想做几年的事。而对于我爸爸来说，就像：我要在以色列的基布兹度过我的一生。然后他们相爱了，她劝说他搬到温哥华，与新泽西州的纽瓦克相比，温哥华在很多方面就像以色列的基布兹，我爸爸就是那里人。
And so, yeah, so it makes, you know, that's how they got that. And they were like, you know, they were very left wing by like Canadian standards, you know? So like they were always very like, like they're like socialists, you know, and my mother was a social worker. And like that's like my sister's a social worker and my half brother's a social worker. Like that became is like a career that kind of like ran in my family. And my dad would like work at various like nonprofits, but never in like the same job.
所以，是的，这就说得通了，（笑）他们就是这样走到一起的。而且他们，你知道的，按照加拿大的标准，他们是非常左翼的，你知道吗？所以他们总是非常像，就像社会主义者，你知道的，我母亲是一名社工。就像，我姐姐是一名社工，我同父异母的弟弟也是一名社工。这成了一种在我家族里世代相传的职业。我爸爸会在各种非营利组织工作，但从来不是同一份工作。
Like he dropped out of Rutgers and moved to Israel. And he like never had like, he was never like a career guy. Like he always admittedly like hated working basically so. So he hated working and they were in effect socialists. And then you then you become, you know, and deservedly so incredibly successful in like the basket of capitalism of in Hollywood, do they, do they reject that? Or do they, are they like, this is pretty sweet to know they were thrilled about it. And now they, they, because at the same time, my parents like nice shit is the funny thing.
就像他从罗格斯大学辍学搬到以色列。他从来没有过，他从来不是那种追求职业生涯的人。就像他一直承认的那样，基本上讨厌工作，所以。所以他讨厌工作，而他们实际上是社会主义者。然后你，然后你成为了，你知道的，而且实至名归地在好莱坞的资本主义大熔炉里变得极其成功，他们，他们会排斥这一点吗？还是说，他们会觉得：这感觉挺不错。他们对此欣喜若狂。现在他们，他们因为与此同时，我的父母喜欢好东西，这很有趣。
Like they're more than happy turns out and they always did. Like that's like, even as a kid, we, we, again, we lived in a very like not fantastic house in a not fantastic neighborhood and did not have a lot of the fancy things that people have. I never had a car. We didn't, any of that shit, you know, but like, but we would go to Disneyland on vacation every single year. Like they liked, they liked going on vacation and shit.
就像结果证明他们非常乐意，而且他们一直都这样。就像，甚至在我还是个孩子的时候，我们，我们，再次强调，我们住在一个非常不咋样的社区里一个非常不咋样的房子里，也没有人们拥有的许多昂贵的的东西。我从来没有过车。我们也没有任何那些乱七八糟的东西，你知道的，但是，但是我们每年暑假都会去迪士尼乐园度假。就像他们喜欢，他们喜欢去度假之类的东西。
Like they, they always liked like fun things. They just didn't prior, they prioritized their. Everybody's still close. Yes. Very close. Oh, that's good. They are still happily spending my money. Do they live near you?
就像，他们一直喜欢有趣的事情。他们只是不把……排在优先位置。大家现在还很亲密吗？是的。非常亲密。哦，那太好了。他们仍然在开开心心地花我的钱。他们住在你附近吗？
They have a place in Laguna Beach, which is, yeah, like 45 minutes away and. You mean you have a place in Laguna Beach? Exactly. I have a place in Laguna Beach I've been to once and, but they come stay with us a lot and I see them all the time. And yeah, and I do like my parents like, and I get along well with them and I don't like. That's great. Yeah.
他们在拉古纳海滩有一处房产，也就是，是的，大概45分钟车程远，而且。你是说你在拉古纳海滩有一处房产？没错。我在拉古纳海滩有一处房产，我去过一次，但是他们经常来和我们一起住，我经常见到他们。是的，我很喜欢我的父母，而且我和他们相处得很好，我不喜欢。太棒了。是的。
Like I, I get it. Like, you know, I very much have the thing in me where like I wish I didn't care so much about work and like, and it's, and I've seen my father like have conversations with my friends who are like down on themselves, like where he is trying to impart, like you should not conflate yourself worth and where your career is, which is such a funny thing for my father to be telling people. But he's right. You know what?
就像，我懂的。你知道，我内心深处也有这种想法，比如我希望我没那么在乎工作，而且，而且我见过我父亲和我那些对生活感到沮丧的朋友交谈，他在试图传授经验，比如你不应该把你的自我价值和你的职业发展混为一谈，我父亲竟然会对别人说出这种话，这太有趣了。但他说的对。你知道吗？
Yeah. You're, you're a dad now too, aren't you? I'm not a dad. You're not? No. Would you like to be? Yeah. Tell him, Jay.
是的。你现在也是个爸爸了，对吧？我不是个爸爸。你不是？不是。你想当爸爸吗？想。告诉他，杰伊。
Yeah. Are you giving away your children? Yeah. The eight year old is just like, um, no, I don't know if I want to be, honestly, I don't look at any of my friends with kids enviously, honestly, I, I like the kid. There are a lot of kids in my life. I have nephews. I've, you know, I have, we have a lot of close friends with kids, but I don't.
是的。你要把你的孩子送走吗？是的。那个八岁的孩子就像是，嗯，不，我不知道我想不想当爸爸，说实话，老实说，我并没有羡慕任何有孩子的同行朋友，我喜欢孩子。我的生活中有很多孩子。我有侄子。我，你知道，我们有很多有孩子的密友，但我没有。
I shared this saying, this quote that I read that I now own, and I shared it with Jason and Will, that it was a woman who said it. She said, I'd rather regret not having kids than have them and regret it later. For sure. And me and my wife actively have that conversation where, cause she also does not want to have kids in the same boat as me. And we're like, you know, like we might regret having them for like 50 years at worst, regret not having them for like a couple of years right before we die, you know?
我分享过这句话，我读到过的一句名言，现在我觉得它说得太对了，我把它分享给了杰森和威尔，那是一位女性说的。她说：“我宁愿后悔没有生孩子，也不愿生了孩子后才后悔。”确实如此。我和我妻子积极地讨论过这个问题，因为她也和我一样不想生孩子。我们就在想，你知道，（笑）最坏的情况下，我们可能会后悔50年没有生孩子；而在死前的那几年里，不生孩子的遗憾可能也就是持续一会儿，你知道吗？
Like, that's like, if we're really just talking like worst case scenario, it's like, yeah, but I'm like, when death is very close, that's when I'll be like, shit, maybe it'd be nice to have someone around. But like the decades before that, we're just having a good time. And like, sure. You're free to do what you want. And I've had this conversation with Ricky Jervis a few times and he's always like, I, he resents people who are like, why don't you have kids?
就像，如果我们真的在讨论最坏的情况，那就是这样，但我会觉得，当死神临近时，我才会想：操，身边有个人可能会挺好的。但在那之前的几十年里，我们只是在过得很开心。所以，当然。你可以随心所欲。我和里奇·热维斯讨论过几次这个问题，他总是说，他，他讨厌那些问“你为什么不生孩子”的人。
He's like, what do you mean that there's, there's no obligation to have them. And also I just had my third son and quick, what's his name, you got me, you got me again. This is the 12th time you've got me on this, but, but, but I sent him, you know, and so he's got no kids and he's happy about, and so I sent him a, like I said with everybody else, I sent him a sort of a text saying my son was born and I'd get back, I'm Zep emoji. Perfect. Perfect. Perfect.
他说：你这话什么意思，生孩子又不是义务。而且，我刚刚迎来了我的第三个儿子，快说，他叫什么名字？你又来了，你又套路我了。这是你第12次用这个梗套路我了，但是，但是，我给他发了，你知道的，所以他没有孩子，他对现状很满意，于是我给他发了一条，就像我对其他人一样，我发了一条短信说我儿子出生了，我回头回复你，我用了齐柏林飞船（Zep）的表情符号。完美。完美。完美。
You know, and if I told him about some bid I had done, we'd go back and forth for half an hour, but no, well, truthfully, a good bid is, you know, slightly more of an accomplishment in some ways. It's a smaller bullseye to hit. The dumbest of motherfuckers have kids, I hate to say, and it was, I was talking to one of my good friends who was a mother who has kids and she was going on and on about how beautiful it is and how hard it is at times and the challenges and the ups and downs and at the end she's like, but at the end of the day, a monkey could do it and they fucking
你知道的，如果我跟他聊起我做过的某个喜剧包袱，我们能来回聊上半个小时，但说实话，一个好的喜剧包袱在某种程度上更算是一种成就。它的靶心更小，更难命中。最蠢的混蛋都有孩子，我讨厌这么说。我曾和我的一个好朋友交谈过，她是一个有孩子的母亲，她滔滔不绝地讲述着当母亲是多么美好，有时又是多么艰难，其中的挑战、起起落落。最后她说：“但归根结底，猴子也能生，而且它们他妈的还真生。”
do it. They're not that different. A monkey baby is not a lot harder to keep alive or easier to keep alive than a human one. And they figure that shit out. So I think like, yeah, I mean, but it's great. If you're a great parent and you produce, like, that's the thing is like, I think whoever like Albert Einstein's parents are should be famous.
它们并没有太大区别。要让一只小猴子活下来，并不比让一个人类小孩活下来困难多少，也容易多少。它们自己就把那事儿给琢磨透了。所以我觉得，是的，不过这很棒。如果你是一个伟大的父母，并且培养出了……问题就在于，我觉得，不管是谁，阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦的父母应该出名才对。
You know what I mean? We don't actually, we don't actually incentivize parents to have good kids. We incentivize kids to become good people and they will maybe get praise, but more emphasis should be put on raising good children. Absolutely. I always think, you know, they're, and I'm not even kidding. You should have to pass a test to be a parent. Oh, for sure.
你知道我的意思吗？我们实际上，我们并没有真正激励父母去培养优秀的孩子。我们激励孩子们成为优秀的人，他们可能会得到赞扬，但更多的重点应该放在如何抚养优秀的孩子上。绝对是的。我一直认为，你知道，他们，我甚至不是在开玩笑。你应该通过一项测试才能成为父母。哦，肯定的。
I agree with that. I don't know why we don't do that. And you should have to redo it as well. Just like driver's licenses, you know, that's exactly right. You know, Jason just met both of his kids recently and, you know, right when he wrapped Ozark season three and he came back from Atlanta. Have you tried to recast them since you met them? You're used to more control than this is not what I pictured.
我同意这一点。我不知道为什么我们不这样做。而且你还得定期重新参加测试。就像驾照一样，你知道，完全正确。你知道，杰森最近刚刚见到了他的两个孩子，你知道的，就在他拍完《黑钱胜地》第三季从亚特兰大回来之后。自从你见过他们后，你有没有尝试重新选角？你习惯了更多的控制，这不是你想象的那样。
I want to get back to writing because of all the, you know, occupations in Hollywood, the writing, directing, producing, acting, whatever it is, writing to me is, I enjoy, but it takes a while for me to get there where you're just unbelievably prolific at it. And it does take a lot of brain power and discipline and a lot of a headspace and dark rooms and isolation. And do you enjoy that part of it? No, that's photography with the dark room. Oh, sorry.
我想回到写作上来，因为在好莱坞的所有职业中，写作、导演、制片、表演，无论是什么，对我来说，写作是我很享受的，但我需要花一段时间才能进入状态，而你在这一行高产得令人难以置信。这确实需要大量的脑力、纪律性、大量的心理空间、黑暗的房间和独处。你喜欢那一部分吗？不，那是摄影才有的暗室。哦，抱歉。
I have my notes wrong. I write in photos, which is what a lot of people don't know that. I, no, for me, I think I've been doing it for so long, like we started when we were so young, I think, like that it really, it's, it's, it's honestly the thing I feel the most control over. So it is the thing I'm probably the most comfortable doing. It's like, as soon as we're on set and there's a million fucking people around and shit, that's when I get more stressed out, honestly, because it's like, Oh no, it's like now I have
我的笔记记错了。我是用照片写作的，这是很多人不知道的。不，对我来说，我觉得我做这件事已经很久了，因为我们开始得很早，所以我觉得，老实说，这是我感觉最有掌控感的事情。所以它可能是我做起来最舒服的事情。就像，一旦我们到了片场，周围有一百万个该死的人之类的，那就是我压力最大的时候，老实说，因为就像：哦不，就像现在我
to make this real. And like, it's when I'm, when we're writing, it's just me in heaven and we're hanging out and we're smoking weed and we're making each other laugh. And it's like, it feels like we're, we're 14 years old still, you know, right? Have your roles or lanes changed significantly in, in how you guys write in, in how you guys direct or do you guys kind of still kind of manage the same sides of the street or as you've gotten older, have you guys overlapped a little bit more switch sides of the street or?
必须把这个变成现实。而就像，当我，当我们在写作时，那简直是我的天堂，我们在闲逛，我们在抽大麻，我们在逗彼此笑。感觉就像我们还是14岁的小孩一样，对吧？你们的角色或分工在你们的写作方式、导演方式上有没有发生过显著的变化？或者你们基本上还是管理街道的同一侧，还是说随着年龄的增长，你们有一点点重叠、换过街道的一侧，还是？
No, it's pretty much the same. Like, and we never had like lanes specifically, like we were never one of like, I'm the story guy and he's the dialogue guy, like we've worked with people like that and teams like that. And, and again, even with our movies, it was never like, yeah, like you talk to the actors and I'll talk to the camera, like if we all like our skill set is humiliatingly overlapping and redundant. And I think it really is like we are, we are like, we have things that one will see that
不，基本上是一样的。而且我们从来没有过具体的分工，比如我们从来不是那种：“我是负责剧情的，他是负责对话的”这种人，我们和那种人和那种团队合作过。而且，即使是在我们的电影里，也从来没有过：“你去和演员交流，我去和摄影机交流”这种事。如果我们所有人——我们的技能组合有着令人尴尬的重叠和冗余。而且我认为这真的就像我们是，我们就像，一个人能看到的东西
the other won't, but we are generally like our sensibilities were very much formed together, you know. And so I think we very much see things the same more than anything. But that's an interesting, that's an interesting point though, because Jason, I see you and legitimately knowing that you're asking that question because that confuses you a little bit. You're, you're much more, you think a long term of people having various lanes. Am I right?
另一个人看不到，但总体上我们的审美是在一起形成的，你知道的。所以我觉得比起别的，我们在很大程度上对事物的看法是一致的。但这是一个有趣的，这是一个有趣的观点，因为杰森，我看到你，而且我完全知道你问这个问题是因为那让你有点糊涂。你更倾向于，你认为人们有各自长期的不同分工。我说的对吗？
I'm not even doing a bit. Yes and no, I mean, it's mostly out of sort of respect and delegating, you know, departments and all that stuff. But I really admire duos that are comfortable with overlap and redundancies and, and not being overly sort of territorial, you know, like, oh, no, I'm dialogue, your story. Like, I like that people can play nicely in the sandbox together. That's probably why you guys have been so incredibly successful and for so long. Now, what about how, what, what's your ideal rhythm of work?
我甚至不是在开玩笑。可以说是，也可以说不是，我的意思是，这主要出于某种尊重、授权分工、还有所有那些乱七八糟的事情。但我真的很佩服那些习惯于重叠和冗余、并且不过于划分地盘的双人组，你知道的，比如：“哦，不，我是管对白的，你是管剧情的”。我喜欢人们能在同一个沙坑里愉快地一起玩耍。这大概就是为什么你们俩能够取得如此巨大的成功，而且一火就是这么多年。那么，关于你们的理想工作节奏是什么样的？
Do you like to be working as much as you do? And it seems like every single year you guys are even more and more invited to and creating opportunity and access. And I mean, it's, it's, you could probably work 365 days of the year. Right? I mean, it's nice that, yeah, I mean, so far so good, I guess I do. Are you wanting to respond? Are you wanting to respond to all the opportunity or would you rather be doing less?
你喜欢像现在这样高强度地工作吗？看起来好像每年你们都会受到更多的邀请，并创造出更多的机会和渠道。我的意思是，这，你大概一年365天都在工作吧？对吧？我是说，这挺好的，是的，我的意思是，目前为止一切顺利，我想是的。你想要回应吗？你想要回应所有的机会，还是你宁愿少做一点？
Like if you, if you've created a monster that's too big, no, actually this year was the first time like me and Evan haven't like written and directed a movie in a very long time. Like even the interview, we didn't, we like someone else wrote the screenplay and we were kind of doing other things and like, but like, I think this is the end was the last movie that we wrote and directed and it was like seven years ago. So, and we realized it was because we just weren't giving ourselves the time to sit down and actually dedicate how much time it takes to write an entire movie from beginning to end.
就像如果你创造了一个太大的怪物，不，其实今年是我和埃文很长一段时间以来第一次没有写和导演电影。就像即使是《采访》，我们也没有，我们就像是别人写了剧本，而我们在忙别的事情，但是，就像，我觉得《世界末日》是我们写和导演的最后一部电影，那是大约七年前的事了。所以，我们意识到这是因为我们没有给自己留出时间坐下来，真正投入创作一部从头到尾的电影所需要的时间。
Cause for us, that takes like a year around. And so that was something like this year was the first time I like kind of set aside several things that I probably would have normally done, but would have distracted me from doing the thing that I probably should have been doing, which was just like sitting down and writing a movie basically. So yeah, it's, there was, but there's been like deliberate, you know, we deliberately like spent a lot of time directing television, for example, cause we had directed two movies and we felt like we could learn a lot, but we were also a little frustrated with how long
因为对我们来说，那需要大概一年的时间。所以那是，比如今年是我第一次把一些我通常可能会做、但会分散我精力的事情先搁置一边，而那些事本来是我应该去做的，也就是坐下来写一部电影，基本上就是这样。所以，是的，曾经有过，但也有过刻意的，你知道的，我们刻意花了很多时间去导演电视剧，比如说，因为我们导演了两部电影，我们觉得我们可以学到很多东西，但我们也对导演电影所需的时间感到有点沮丧，就学习东西而言。所以我们当时想：“哦，我们会在接下来的几年里导演五部电视剧，这会帮我们在一个更浓缩的时间段里尝试各种各样的事情。”所以那是一个非常刻意的决定。然后我们大约在一年前刚从那种状态中走出来。也就是在那时，你知道的，我本来可能会去拍别人的电影，但这就是那种一直隐约浮现、我可能随时会去做的东西。但今年我，但我已经很久没这么做了。
it took to direct a movie as far as like learning things go. So we were like, oh, we'll direct like five TV shows over the course of the next few years and that'll help us try a bunch of shit in like a much more condensed time period. So that was like a very deliberate thing we did. And then we just kind of came out of that like a year ago. And that's when, you know, I was maybe going to go act in other people's movies, but that's, that's kind of the thing that like is always looming that I maybe will go do. But this year I, but I haven't in quite some time on it.
所以你一直在做，所以你一直在电视和电影之间来回切换，我有很长一段时间，我觉得我和很多人都探讨过这个话题，但我发现我自己的经验是，我总是开玩笑说，如果不是因为烂电影，我一部也拍不出来。但如果，如果为电视拍喜剧和为电影拍喜剧的区别是——我总是说，因为电视的本质要求你必须不断地向前推进，它的节奏要快得多，它更适合——至少对我来说，作为一个表演者，我发现拍喜剧电影的过程要漫长得多，我会感到厌烦
So you've been doing, so you've been going back and forth between TV and, I have long sort of, I feel like I've had this conversation with a bunch of different people, but I find it's, my own experience was, and I always joke that if it wasn't for bad movies, I wouldn't make any. But if, if the difference between making a comedy for TV and comedy for film, for a movie is, I always said, because, because the very nature of TV that you have to keep moving in a long, that there is a much quicker pace, that it lends itself to, for me anyway, certainly as a performer, I find the process of making a comedy film so much longer and I get bored
所以你一直在做，所以你一直在电视和电影之间来回切换，我一直以来有一种感觉，我好像和很多人都聊过这个话题，但我发现，我自己的经历是，我总是开玩笑说，要不是拍了些烂片，我什么片也拍不成了。但是，如果说为电视拍喜剧和为电影拍喜剧的区别在于，我总是说，因为电视的本质决定了你必须不断地推进，节奏要快得多，这使得——至少对我来说，作为一个表演者——我发现拍喜剧电影的过程要漫长得多，而且我很容易感到无聊
and it's not as fun. And then, and then I lose interest and they're just, I lose that immediacy of doing the bit, fucking around and moving on, which keeps me going as long as we keep moving, I will keep fucking around. And if you, and if it's all of a sudden takes 10 hours to shoot one side of a scene, like I'm gone. And I can't. Yeah.
而且也没那么有趣了。然后，然后我就失去了兴趣，那种即兴发挥、瞎胡闹然后继续前进的即时感就没了，正是这种状态支撑着我继续下去，只要我们一直在前进，我就会一直瞎胡闹。但如果你，如果突然花10个小时去拍一个场景的一侧，我就待不下去了。我做不到。是的。
I can, I can attest to that. I work with Will many times. And when we turn around on me, it's, I'm like, Will, where did he go? Where did he go? Yeah. I, I mean, I actually do, one of the things that was most fascinating about doing this was seeing how like TV and movies are two vastly different mediums and people who are good in TV, like there are people who are good at both, but just because you are good
我能，我能作证。我和威尔合作过很多次。当我们把镜头转向我时，我就想：威尔，他去哪儿了？他去哪儿了？是的。我的意思是，我其实，做这件事最让人着迷的事情之一，就是看到电视和电影是两种截然不同的媒介，那些在电视上表现出色的人——虽然有人两方面都很擅长，但仅仅因为你擅长
at one, it does not mean you'll be good at the other. And people think that that is the case. And I've been front row on several occasions to the startling realization that it is not at all the case and that just because you are good at writing television, it doesn't mean you're good at writing movies and vice versa. And I actually find myself, I actually have kind of the exact opposite thing in a way. Like I think my brain is so geared towards film writing and my understanding of how a film works and is structured and how that is, how there's a beginning and a middle and
其中一个，并不意味着你就能擅长另一个。人们往往以为是这样的。而且我有好几次在前排亲眼目睹了那个令人震惊的现实：根本就不是那么回事儿，仅仅因为你擅长写电视剧，并不意味着你擅长写电影，反之亦然。而且我发现自己，我其实正好有完全相反的感受。就像我觉得我的大脑太倾向于电影剧作了，我对电影如何运作、如何构建、以及如何存在起承转合有着深刻的理解。对我来说，那是，我对此有很好的理解。而一旦我们转向电视，作为一个编剧，我基本上就废了。我可以帮忙处理一些整体的事情和角色相关的事情，但对于一集接一集的事情，我能提供的帮助微乎其微，而且我也不想提供太多。当然，对于写作来说是这样，但对于表演者或观察表演者呢？老实说，情况是一样的。
an end. And that to me is like, I have a very good understanding of that. And as soon as we switch to television, like as a writer, I'm essentially useless. Like I can help with like total things and character things, but like on an episode to episode thing, I have very little to offer and I do not try to offer that much. Sure. For writing, but what about for a performer or observing performers? It's the same thing, honestly.
当我感觉到某样东西本可以更好而我们却做不到时，我会感到沮丧。对于电影，我习惯了那种节奏：等我们拍完一个场次时，我会觉得基本可以确信，我们没有拍好绝不是因为不够努力。因为你们有时间。是的。我们有时间，我们有时间停下来思考，去真正思考，而且我的一部分喜欢——这很有趣，因为我曾把电视剧在某种程度上称作是一次性的，我觉得甚至在制作它的人眼中也是如此，因为
Like I get frustrated when I feel like something could be better and we aren't able to do it. And with film, I'm used to the pace where like by the time we're done shooting a scene, I'm like pretty sure we, you know, it won't have been for lack of effort that we've not. Because you had the time. Yeah. We have the time and we have time to stop and think and to really think like, and part of me likes, it's funny because like I've referred to it as like a disposability to some degree that TV has, I think in the eyes of the people who are making it even because
就像当我感觉事情可以做得更好而我们却做不到时，我会感到沮丧。在电影制作中，我习惯了这样的节奏：当一场戏拍完时，我基本上可以确定，你知道，我们没有做到绝不是因为缺乏努力。因为你有时间。对的。我们有时间，我们有时间停下来思考，深入地思考，我的一部分甚至喜欢这种感觉——这很有趣，因为我有时会认为电视剧在某种程度上有一种“用过即弃”的性质，甚至在制作它的人眼中也是如此，因为
like it's like, ah, if this episode is not great, the next one will be good, but movies aren't like that. Like they have to be good every, as good as you could make them every second because like that's it. And you'll be watching TVS in 20 years and it'll be on, you know, and you have to like live with the fact that like, oh, shit, like we could have made that joke better and people are still watching it, you know, and, and like that, I'm actually more comfortable with that.
就像是：“啊，如果这一集不够好，下一集会好的”，但电影不是这样的。每一部分都必须尽你所能做到最好，因为那就定型了。你20年后还在看电视重播，它还在播，你知道的，你不得不接受这样一个事实：哦，操，我们本可以把那个笑话写得更好，而人们现在还在看，你知道的，而且，对于这一点，我其实更适应。
And that like, I like that everyone is geared towards like, we got to make this as good as humanly possible every second, instead of being geared towards like, let's keep going. Like, yeah, it's fun. Let's just, let's just keep going. Do you enjoy that kind of, do you have like a self-imposed pressure to always, you know, being funny is exhausting, you know, like, like constantly writing funny things, you know what I mean?
而且我喜欢每个人都朝着这个方向努力：我们必须在每一秒钟把这东西做到人力所及的极致，而不是想着：我们继续吧。就像，是的，这很有趣。我们就继续拍吧。你喜欢那种，你是否有一种强加给自己的压力，永远要——你知道，搞笑是很累人的，你知道的，就像，不断地写搞笑的东西，你知道我的意思吗？
What's that? Being around it is. Yeah, right. That's for sure. But you know what I mean? Like the business of it, the business of having to be funny and writing and performing, whatever. Do you ever get tired of it and do you have a self-imposed, what you, what you were just talking about, do you have a self-imposed kind of pressure that you enjoy or you hate
什么意思？身处其中确实很累。是的，没错。但你知道我的意思吗？就像这件事的商业运作，必须搞笑、写作、表演等等的这种商业压力。你有没有对此感到厌倦过？你有没有一种强加给自己的压力——就像你刚才说的——那种你享受或者讨厌的压力，
about, I have to deliver the best, I have to be the funniest, this has to, this is not good enough, you know, because a lot of people that gets, it kind of carves away at them after a while. Yeah, I enjoy doing it, but I hate the scrutiny of it. Like I, I like, I like the act of doing it. And when we're making movies, it can be exhausting and, but if I think it's actually good, what we're doing, which I very much try to only put myself in situations where that is the case.
关于：我必须呈现出最好的效果，我必须是最搞笑的，这必须达到标准，这还不够好，你知道的，因为对许多人来说，这种压力过一段时间后会像蚕食一样侵蚀他们。是的，我很享受创作的过程，但我讨厌对它的审视。就像，我喜欢，我喜欢去做的那个行为。当我们在拍电影时，这可能会让人筋疲力尽，但如果我认为我们做的事情实际上很好——我非常努力地只让自己处于那种情况中。
And thankfully for quite some time, I haven't looked around and found myself in a situation where I genuinely didn't feel that was the case. It's, it's, yeah, it's fun and I look forward to it and I get up like excited that I might be making something that I'll be proud of for a long time. Do you ever feel like giving yourself a break from that pressure of having to be funny or making sure that it's funny and taking something easier, like a drama? Yeah, I've done it a few times. That was my question, but much shorter.
谢天谢地，在相当长的一段时间里，我没有环顾四周，发现自己身处一种我真心觉得情况并非如此的境况。这，是的，这很有趣，我很期待，我醒来时会感到兴奋，因为我可能在创作一件能让我引以为傲很久的作品。你有没有想过让自己从这种必须搞笑、或者确保它很好笑的压力中解脱出来，去尝试一些轻松的事情，比如正剧？是的，我试过几次。那是我的问题，不过简短得多。
Yeah, I've done it, I've done it a few times. And it is, it is, it's more, it is easier for sure. Like that's the Steve Jobs movie was probably like the easiest thing I've ever done. Yeah, you were awesome on that. Thank you. And it was, and it's so funny because me and Jonah Hill have talked about this a lot because he also switches back and forth from drama to comedy, you know, and we're always like, I remember when he was shooting Moneyball, he's like, what's so annoying is I know this
是的，我做过，我试过几次。而且确实，它确实更容易。就像史蒂夫·乔布斯那部电影可能是我拍过的最轻松的电影了。是的，你在那部电影里棒极了。谢谢。而且，很有趣，我和乔纳·希尔经常讨论这个，因为他也在正剧和喜剧之间来回切换，你知道的，我们总是说——我记得他在拍《点球成金》时，他说：“最烦人的是，我知道这会给我带来比我做过的任何事都要多的赞誉，而且它比我做过的绝大多数事情都要轻松得多，你知道吗？”这就是为什么当他因《华尔街之狼》获得提名时，我超级兴奋，因为它实际上是一场喜剧表演，而且是一次巨大的冒险，它既是一次伟大的表演，也是一件我知道很有挑战性、对喜剧演员来说绝非轻而易举的事，你知道的。但随后我听说，然后我听说他执导的那部电影棒极了。
is going to get me more acclaimed than anything I've ever done. And it's like so much easier than most of the things I've done, you know, and that's why when he got nominated for Wolf of Wall Street, I was so psyched because it was actually like a, like a comedic performance and like a big swing and it was like, it was something that was both great and, and like something that I knew was challenging and not like a walk in the park for a comedian, you know. But yeah. And then I hear, and then I hear his film is fantastic that he directed.
会比我以往做过的任何事情都更能为我赢得赞誉。而且这比我做过的大多数事情都要简单得多，你知道的，这就是为什么当他因《华尔街之狼》获得提名时，我超级兴奋，因为这实际上就像是一场喜剧表演，是一次巨大的尝试，它既出色，又是我知道充满挑战、对喜剧演员来说并非易事的表演，你知道的。但确实如此。然后我听说，然后我听说他导演的那部电影棒极了。
I haven't seen it yet. Oh, it's great. But I just did a great job with that. It's so good. Yeah. And, and, and it does both in a really good way, you know, like it's, but yeah, it's, it's tempting. And actually it just takes, it's, it's so much less rewarding in some ways, unless it's
我还没看过呢。哦，它太棒了。不过那个我确实演得很好。真的很好。对。而且，而且它把这两者结合得非常好，你知道吧，就像它，但是，是的，这，这很诱人。而且实际上它需要，从某些方面来说，它的回报要少得多，除非是
like a director that I'm like, oh, I like have to work with this person or like it's someone I've always looked up to. I really think I could learn something just from being around them. Then, then it's, yeah, then it's like, I think when I was younger, I wanted to like show I could do it and I was sick of how little respect comedians get, but now I just like have accepted that that is the way of the world and, and, and we should, and we just Academy Awards would have a comedy category. I was just going to say that it's mind blowing that the Oscars have a comedy.
那种让我觉得，哦，我好像必须和这个人合作，或者像是我一直很崇拜的人。我真的觉得只要能跟他们在一起，我就能学到东西。那样的话，那就，是的，那就变成了，我觉得当我年轻的时候，我想证明我能做到，而且我厌倦了喜剧演员得到的尊重那么少，但现在我只是接受了这就是世界运转的方式，而且，而且，我们应该，而且我们应该——奥斯卡应该设立一个喜剧类奖项。我正想说这个，奥斯卡没有喜剧类别简直让人难以置信。
Well, it's funny. Yeah. How like no one really talks about how like if the Emmys didn't, no fucking comedy would win an Emmy ever. The only reason it happens is because they realize like, oh, we got to carve out a whole fucking category for this. Yeah. Right.
好吧，这很有趣。是的，就像没有人真正讨论过，如果艾美奖没有设立这个奖项，他妈的根本不会有喜剧赢得艾美奖。它能发生的唯一原因是因为他们意识到，哦，我们得为此开辟出一个他妈的全新类别。对吧。没错。
Right. Otherwise they wouldn't be giving it to them. And trailers should have a category at the Oscars. It's such an important part of the business. And they're like little mini movies and, and announcements, announcements and deadlines should have a category. Yeah. Good announcement.
没错。否则他们根本不会颁给他们。而且预告片也应该在奥斯卡上设立一个奖项。这是这个行业如此重要的一部分。它们就像微型电影一样，还有发布会，发布会和截止日期也应该设立一个奖项。对。一个好的发布会。
A really like a solid one. Yeah. Paramount ankles, VP goes to ankles. Can I get your take on any sort of validation you feel about weed becoming legalized now and no one has to like sort of hide it anymore. You just, oh, I just always thought you were so courageous about how forthright you were about that you enjoy weed and that you smoke it and like who get, and like all, and now of a sudden it's legal and you can buy it like a, like a, like there, there's more weed
真的是一个很扎实的发布会。对。派拉蒙的Ankles，副总裁去了Ankles。我能听听你对大麻现在合法化这件事有什么看法吗，没有人再需要藏着掖着了，你可以随便——哦，我一直觉得你对待大麻的态度非常勇敢，你那么直言不讳地说你喜欢大麻而且你还抽它，就像谁懂，就像所有人，现在突然之间它合法了，你可以像买——像买东西一样去买，现在那里的商店
shops than Starbucks nowadays. It's great. So do you feel any sort of validation about that? Yeah. Yeah. Very much. It's about time. It's nice that people are acknowledging that like the war on drugs was a hundred percent
比星巴克还多。这太棒了。所以你对此有什么被认可的感觉吗？对。是的。非常有。这是迟来的正义。人们开始承认禁毒战争百分之百是
bullshit. Yeah. And, and it is not like, you know, disconnected from people's realization that like almost every fundamental part of American life is some way tied into systemic racism and the, and the fact that weed is illegal is no different from that in any way, shape or form. And so it, I mean, it is very validating for all those reasons. And just as someone who smokes weed all day, it's nice to see it having worked its way into culture in a way that it isn't stigmatized and as much and that people are accepting
一堆废话，这挺好的。对。而且这并不是说，你知道的，这跟人们意识到美国生活的几乎每个基础部分都以某种方式与系统性种族主义交织在一起是毫无关系的，而且大麻违法这一点在任何形式、形状或方式上都与此没有什么不同。所以，我的意思是，基于所有这些原因，这真的很有认同感。而且作为一个整天都在抽大麻的人来说，看到它融入文化中，不再被那么 stigmatized（污名化），人们开始接受
that it is, you know, a part of life. Yeah. That's such a great point because obviously the war on drugs were just another, whether it's weed or cocaine or whatever, it was all just varying levers of control used to suppress and to kind of enforce this systemic racism that has just lived here forever. And then now imagine if all the time and money and resources that were spent on the war on drugs, imagine if all of that had been dedicated to you name it. Yeah.
它是生活的一部分，这感觉很好。对。这真是个极好的观点，因为很明显，禁毒战争只是另一种控制手段，不管是大麻、可卡因还是别的什么，都只是用来压制和强行推行这种永远存在于此的系统性种族主义的不同程度的权力杠杆。然后，想象一下，如果把所有花在禁毒战争上的时间、金钱和资源，想象一下如果所有这些都投入到——随便你命名什么。对。
Yeah. Right. Anything else in the world. Anything else in the world. Yeah. Any other resources that was poured into the war on drugs and the war in Afghanistan and Iraq. Imagine what a different fucking place we would live in.
对。对。世界上任何其他东西。世界上任何其他东西。对。任何投入到禁毒战争以及阿富汗和伊拉克战争中的资源。想象一下，我们将会生活在一个多么截然不同的他妈的地方啊。
However, that can never happen. And hopefully we're now at the turning point. And it's funny that weed is such a, weirdly such a big part of that too. Oh yeah, for sure. I mean, yeah, I mean, it really is. And it was, I mean, if you just take something everyone likes and that almost everyone does and you only arrest certain people for it, it can become a very powerful weapon. And that is unfortunately what it's been for a long time.
然而，那永远不会发生。希望我们现在正处于转折点。有趣的是，大麻竟然也是其中如此重要的一部分，这真的很奇怪。哦，是的，肯定的。我是说，是的，我的意思是，它确实是。而且它曾经是——我的意思是，如果你拿走一样人人都喜欢而且几乎人人都做的事情，并且只因此逮捕某些人，它就会变成一件非常强大的武器。不幸的是，长期以来它就是这样。
And so I think morally, just from a moral standpoint, it is nice that this thing that I've talked about for so long, and that's always been something I've been aware of, is I've been making movies about smoking weed, I've been out there, I've been smoking weed at fucking award shows and shit like that, and people go to jail for that. And there are people in jail for that, you know? And that's always bothered me, honestly. Did you ever get threatened for that? Did anybody ever kind of reach out at any point?
所以我认为在道德上，仅仅从道德的角度来看，我谈论了这么久的事情终于被接纳了，这感觉很好，而且这也是我一直意识到的事情，我一直在拍关于抽大麻的电影，我在公众场合露面，我在他妈的颁奖典礼之类的活动上抽大麻，而人们却会为此入狱。而且确实有人因此坐牢，你知道吗？老实说，这一直让我很困扰。你曾经为此受到过威胁吗？有没有人在任何时候联系过你？
No. Never. I've had cops ask to smoke weed with me. Wow. Wow. So, at what place or what's the event or what is the day or what is the mood time of day where you would go for a gummy versus a joint versus a bong? I have pretty much only smoked joints.
没有。从来没有。我甚至遇到过警察问能不能跟我一起抽大麻。哇。哇。那么，在什么地方，或者什么活动，或者什么日子，或者在一天中的什么心情/时间，你会选择软糖（gummy）而不是关节烟（joint）或者水烟筒（bong）呢？我基本上只抽关节烟。
Only joints. Never a bong, never an edible. I use a bong sometimes. Like if I'm going to a movie or something and need to try to get as much weed in my brain as possible before, an edible might come into, an edible might be for like a long movie. Like a Marvel film, perhaps. Do you enjoy rolling, do you enjoy rolling joints or do you buy them pre-rolled?
只抽关节烟。从不抽水烟筒，也从不用可食用大麻。我有时代替着抽水烟筒。比如我要去看电影什么的，需要在之前尽可能让我的大脑吸收最多的大麻，这时候可食用大麻就派上用场了，可食用大麻可能适合看一部很长的电影。比如漫威电影，也许吧。你喜欢自己卷烟，还是喜欢买预卷好的？
I don't enjoy rolling them, but no pre-rolled joint smokes to my liking, so I do roll my own joints. When was the last, have you ever done a bucket bong? Yeah. A gravity bong, of course. Yeah. When was the last time you think you did a gravity bong? Not that.
我不喜欢卷烟，但是没有哪个预卷的烟能合我的心意，所以我还是自己卷烟。上一次——你做过重力水烟筒吗？对。重力水烟筒，当然做过。对。你觉得你上一次做重力水烟筒是什么时候？倒不是说那个。
Embarrassingly, not that long ago. What is that? What is that? It's where you use like the top half of a bottle or bucket to suction air and smoke into a, it's kind of complicated. So when I smoke weed, I have panic attacks, which is why I stopped smoking it. And then so I ate it and went to sleep the entire night with my eyes open. So I can't, like, I-
说出来怪不好意思的，没多久以前。那是什么？那是什么？就是你用瓶子的上半部分或者水桶来产生吸力，把空气和烟吸到一个——这挺复杂的。所以当我抽大麻时，我会惊恐发作（panic attacks），这就是为什么我不再抽它的原因。然后我就吃了它，结果整晚睁着眼睛睡觉。所以我不能，就像，我——
Sean's working on a new show called Geeks and Geeks. So and everybody's like, you know, everybody's like, well, you got a sativa, indica, like all that. No, I'm telling you, like, it doesn't- How much of it did you smoke? I used to smoke it for years. But how much did you smoke the last time you had it? Oh, that last time?
肖恩正在筹备一个新节目叫《极客与极客》（Geeks and Geeks）。所以每个人都说，你知道的，每个人都说，哦，你有萨提凡（sativa）、因狄卡（indica），诸如此类。不，我告诉你，这不——你抽了多少？我抽了好多年了。但你上次抽的时候抽了多少？哦，最后那次？
I did, like, a vape thing and I did, like, I don't know, two puffs. Yeah, vapes are, I don't personally trust vape pens that much either. Like, I don't know what that is and like, I think, and that's a different experience as well. Like, I would put that in its own bucket. Like, smoking a joint and hitting a vape pen give you very different solutions. Yeah, but it makes you, makes me not want to ever try it again. That's how bad it was.
我弄了个电子烟之类的东西，然后我抽了，大概两口吧。对，电子烟，我自己其实也不是很信任电子烟笔。就像，我不知道那是什么，而且我觉得，这也是一种不同的体验。我会把它归为另一类。抽关节烟和抽电子烟笔给你的体验完全不同。对，但它让我，让我再也不想尝试了。事情就是这么糟糕。
Now, do you like going to these stores and buying your weed or do you grow your own? I don't grow my own. I- I'm sure you have at some point, right? Does the government know about your huge growth operation? Yeah, exactly. No, you can grow your own legally, can't you? You can.
那么，你喜欢去这些商店买大麻，还是自己种植？我不自己种。我——我确信你曾经种过，对吧？政府知道你的巨大种植基地吗？对，没错。不，你可以合法地自己种植，不是吗？可以的。
I did it in high school. It's not as, I'm not good at growing it, personally. But- Do you like going into the stores and kind of shopping and, and, oh, look at that. Well, now they do, they do delivery. Since the quarantine started, weed delivery has gone up like several hundred percent, I think. So, that is, that is now the way to go.
我在高中时种过。这没有——我自己并不擅长种植。但是——你喜欢走进商店去逛逛，然后，哇，看那个。好吧，现在他们有外卖了。自从隔离开始以来，大麻外卖好像增长了好几百个百分点，我想。所以，那现在是首选方式。
What is the worst drug you've ever done and what happened? The youngest or worst? The worst. Both. Cocaine is objectively the worst drug, I would say. It's terrible. It's the terrible. Cocaine's a bad drug.
你吸过最糟糕的毒品是什么？发生了什么？是最年轻的还是最糟糕的？最糟糕的。两个都说。客观来说，可卡因绝对是最糟糕的毒品，我会这么说。太糟糕了。简直太糟了。可卡因是个坏东西。
Like, I, and, and what's annoying is that it's almost the best drug, like, in that- It can certainly be misused. Yes, there's, there, like, the fact that it, you could, that it's discreet to do and it lasts for, like, a very controllable amount of time and what it does for that amount of time are all good things. Every other thing is terrible about it, like, it, like, you can't stop doing it once you start doing it, essentially. You can't speak, you can't eat, you can't screw.
而且，让我恼火的是，它几乎又是最好的毒品，在某种程度上——它当然会被滥用。是的，有，有——事实上，你可以，它吸食起来很隐蔽，而且药效持续的时间非常可控，在那个时间段内它带给你的效果，这些都是好方面。除此之外的其他方面都糟透了，比如，一旦你开始吸，你就停不下来了，基本上。你不能说话，不能吃东西，不能做爱。
You can't speak, you can't eat, you shit yourself all day, like, but other than that, it's- It sounds like a nursing home. Yeah, and, like, I've been at, like, I remember, like, when my friends were all starting to get married, like, we'd go to bachelor parties and, like, we'd be on acid or shrooms or shit like that and then there'd be, like, the cocaine group in the corner and it was always, like, a dark vibe in the cocaine group in the corner and, like, and every once in a while I would join the cocaine group in the corner and I'm just, like, oh, this is
你不能说话，不能吃东西，你整天都在拉裤子里，除此之外，它——听起来像个疗养院。对，而且，我在——我记得，当我的朋友们开始结婚时，我们会去单身派对，我们可能会嗑迷幻蘑菇（shrooms）或LSD之类的东西，然后角落里总会有一个“可卡因小团体”，角落里的这个可卡因小团体总是散发着一种黑暗的氛围，而且，每隔一段时间我也会加入角落里的可卡因小团体，我就会想，这简直是
such a worse group than the other groups, you know. It's generally the fucking douchebags who are doing coke. It's the worst. It turns everybody into an asshole. Oh, yeah. It's, it's for total chumps and people who can, people who I know who, who still do it today are, are some of the worst people I know. And there's maybe nothing worse on earth than talking to someone on cocaine.
比其他任何团体都要糟糕得多的团体，你知道吗。吸可卡因的通常都是他妈的混蛋。太差劲了。它把每个人都变成了一个混蛋。哦，是的。这，这只适合彻头彻尾的笨蛋，而且我知道那些至今仍在吸它的人，是我认识的最糟糕的人之一。而且世界上可能没有什么比和吸了可卡因的人说话更糟糕的事了。
Oh, my God. It is. And cocaine is not. Unless you're, unless you're also on coke. I was going to say, like, rarely is cocaine good enough to deal with someone on cocaine. I hear it's back, by the way. I hear it's coming back. That's what I hear, that it's everywhere.
哦，天哪。确实是。而且可卡因也不是——除非你，除非你也嗑了。我正要说，和吸了可卡因的人交流，通常不值得你付出那么多精力。顺便说一句，我听说它又卷土重来。我听说它卷土重来了。这就是我听说的，它到处都是。
It keeps coming back every five years. Seth, do you have any, like, crazy drug, drugged out stories that happened? I'll tell mine. It's not hardcore drug story, but one night I couldn't sleep. So I took a cough syrup with a coating in it and I took a lot of it. And then I was like, my nose is kind of stuffed up too. So I took a suit of fed and then I was freaking out like crazy. And Scotty, my husband, he came running up the stairs because he heard a thug, right?
每隔五年它就会卷土重来一次。塞斯，你有什么疯狂的嗑药经历吗？我来讲讲我的。这不是什么硬核毒品的故事，但有天晚上我睡不着。所以我喝了一种含有可待因（codeine）的咳嗽药水，而且我喝了很多。然后我想，我的鼻子也堵得慌。所以我吃了一片伪麻黄碱（Sudafed），然后我就开始疯狂地惊恐发作。斯科蒂，我丈夫，他听到砰的一声就跑上楼梯，因为他听到了一声闷响，对吧？
And I was on the floor again with my eyes open and my head on the floor and stop breathing. And he's like, what? He's like, wake up, wake up. And finally, I went, all of a sudden I went, and I took a deep breath and I woke up like, what's happened? Isn't that nuts? What happened? You were Uma Thurman in Pulp Fiction for a while.
我又倒在地上，双眼圆睁，头贴着地板，停止了呼吸。然后他说，什么？他说，醒醒，醒醒。最后，我突然，我倒吸了一口气，然后醒了过来，心想：发生什么事了？这难道不疯狂吗？发生了什么？你有一段时间就像《低俗小说》里的乌玛·瑟曼。
Yeah, 1000%. What a lightweight. So suit of fed and Vicks with codeine got you. That's not really like a drug store. That's like, this is like a fucking accident, like a domestic accident. Seth's about to bring the noise. I drink bleach and I almost died, is that a bad drug story? I thought rat poison was sugar.
对，千真万确。真是个软蛋。所以伪麻黄碱和含可待因的Vicks把我放倒了。那其实算不上什么毒品故事。那更像是一场他妈的事故，像是一起家里的意外。塞斯要放大招了。我喝了漂白剂差点死掉，这算是一个糟糕的毒品故事吗？我把老鼠药当成糖了。
I didn't know. Sean. No, I love it. I love shit like that. I love drug stories. Where does booze sit for you, Seth? I very rarely drink. I don't like, because I think objectively, alcohol is also a terrible drug, maybe worse
我不知道。肖恩。不，我喜欢。我喜欢这种破事。我喜欢毒品故事。塞斯，酒在你心目中排在什么位置？我极少喝酒。我不喜欢，因为我认为客观来说，酒精也是一种糟糕的毒品，说实话，可能比
than cocaine, honestly. I agree. I agree. I've been on so much shrooms that reality itself ceases to exist and you feel fine the next day. I've had like four glasses of wine at dinner and feel like shit the entire day the next day. They probably made an ass out of yourself while you were drunk.
可卡因还要糟糕。我同意。我同意。我吃过很多迷幻蘑菇，以至于现实本身都不复存在了，但你第二天感觉很好。我晚餐喝了大约四杯葡萄酒，结果第二天一整天都感觉糟透了。你大概在喝醉的时候出过洋相吧。
That is a bad drug if it makes you feel that bad for that long. That's the one that should be outlawed considering how many people die from it and all these car accidents and stuff. Alcohol is the worst drug. I keep going on and on about the pot thing. You've never had a bad experience smoking weed because I want to do it again, but I'm so afraid because of how I was affected by it. I've never really had a bad experience smoking weed.
那确实是一种糟糕的毒品，如果它能让你感觉那么糟糕那么久的话。考虑到那么多人都死于它以及所有的车祸之类的，这才是应该被取缔的毒品。酒精是最糟糕的毒品。我一直在喋喋不休地谈论大麻的事情。你从来没有过吸大麻的糟糕经历吗？因为我想再次尝试，但我太害怕了，因为我之前受到的影响太大了。我从来没有过真正糟糕的吸大麻经历。
I've had bad, like, once at the Golden Globes, I ate a weed lollipop and had to leave. Because you got paranoid? I got so high, I could not, I literally just couldn't, I thought I was keeping it together and I ran into like Brian Cranston at the bathroom and he was just like, what is wrong with you, man? And I was just like, I'm going to fuck out of here. I am not holding this together as well as I thought I was. But what did that look like because you're a lollipop?
我有过糟糕的经历——有一次在金球奖上，我吃了一根大麻棒棒糖，然后不得不离开。因为你产生妄想了？我嗨得太厉害了，我简直无法——我字面意思上就是无法，我以为我还能保持镇定，结果我在洗手间撞见了布莱恩·克兰斯顿，他当时就说：“伙计，你咋了？”而我当时只想说：“我要他妈的离开这里。我根本没有自己想象的那么镇定。”但这看起来是什么样子的，因为你吃的是一根棒棒糖？
I honestly can't. It elicited a strong visceral reaction from someone I did not know that well. It was enough for me to be like, I have to leave now. Did you end up tracking him down and just emailing him and joining like, hey, man. I've never followed up. He knows I'm out there. He's seen me since then, yeah, in the public space. But yeah, no, weed food has fucked me up to the point that I've had very bad experiences.
老实说，我记不清了。它从一个我不是那么熟的人那里引起了强烈而本能的反应。这足以让我觉得：“我必须马上离开这里。”你最后有没有去找他，给他发邮件或者联系他，说：“嘿，伙计。”我从来没跟进过。他知道我还活着。从那以后他见过我，是的，在公共场合。但是，是的，不，大麻食品把我坑惨了，以至于我有过非常糟糕的经历。
On Shrooms, I've been too high a lot, but I'm generally like in someone's house, so it's not like the worst. What does too high look like? Like a bad trip, like crying or paranoia or just laughing too much? This is kind of all of the above within a four hour umbrella of time. Yeah, yeah, I did recently, I did way too many shrooms at a friend's house and it was an experience. I quit two jobs the next morning.
在嗑迷幻蘑菇时，我经常嗨过头，但我通常是在某个人的家里，所以还不算最糟糕的。嗨过头是什么样子的？就像是一次糟糕的旅行（bad trip），比如哭泣、妄想，还是只是笑得太多？这在四个小时的时间范围内，以上这些情况或多或少都有。对，对，我最近在朋友家里嗑了过量的迷幻蘑菇，那真是一次“难忘”的经历。第二天早上我辞掉了两份工作。
That's how high I was. Did your agent know enough to just kind of just let it breathe for 24 hours? No, I actually quit two jobs. Like I actually, there was like two, there was like a thing we were going to direct and another thing I was going to act in and I was like, I was just like, I can't do it. I reached the revelation while high. I can't do these things anymore. And it held.
我当时就是嗨成那样。你的经纪人有足够的眼力劲儿让你先冷静24小时吗？没有，我真的辞了两份工作。实际上我有——当时有两个项目，一个是我们要导演的，另一个是我要演出的，而我当时就觉得——我只是觉得我做不到了。我在嗨的时候顿悟了。我再也不能做这些事情了。而且这个决定坚持了下来。
It held up. I did hold. Wow. I remember a good friend of mine about two years ago, a guy I know, a musician, he called his buddy, he was in his band with, oh, fuck man, it was great. Last night I did Shrooms and I wrote it all down. I wrote some incredible, I had some incredible ideas. I'm so glad you reminded me, hang on one second and he goes and he goes back and he goes,
它确实坚持下来了。我真的坚持了。哇。我记得我一个好朋友，大约两年前，我认识的一个家伙，一个音乐家，他给他乐队里的哥们儿打电话，说：“哦，他妈的，伙计，太棒了。昨晚我嗑了蘑菇，我把一切都写下来了。我写了一些不可思议的东西，我有了一些不可思议的想法。太高兴你提醒我了，等我一下。”然后他回去，接着他说：
man, I wrote all this down and he goes, yeah, yeah, it's total garbage. Sorry. Exactly. I would never pretend I could do something creative on Shrooms. Like I would never, that would not be an, like maybe in the wake of Shrooms, something might arise, but I would never be like, let's do Shrooms and write. You ever try to find them? You ever try to pick them in a field?
“伙计，我把这些都写下来了，”然后他说，“好吧，好吧，这完全是垃圾。对不起。”确实如此。我绝不会假装自己能在嗑了蘑菇的情况下做成什么有创造力的事。我是说我绝不会，那不会是一个——也许在嗑完蘑菇的余韵中，可能会涌现出什么，但我是绝不会说“让我们嗑点蘑菇然后开始写作”的。你试过自己去找它们吗？你试过在田野里采摘它们吗？
No, never. In a sun, in a sun dress with a, with a basket. Do you own a VW van? You're asking, Jason. I once tried to do that with a buddy of mine, it's a crazy cow pasture somewhere and that was, that was. We've talked about it. It's come up.
不，从来没有。穿着阳光裙子，提着一个篮子？你有大众（VW）面包车吗？你在审问我吗，Jason。我曾经和我的一个哥们儿尝试过，那是某个地方一个疯狂的牛场，然后那就是——我们讨论过。这事被提出来过。
We never, we never went there fully. Ended up stepping in a lot of cow shit. Yeah. Sean, have you done Shrooms? I did Shrooms once. Shrooms when I was like 21 and it made me feel like I weighed 800 pounds. You should do them again. I think you should do them again.
我们从未，我们从未真正付诸行动。结果踩了一脚牛屎。对。肖恩，你嗑过蘑菇吗？我嗑过一次蘑菇。我21岁左右的时候嗑过一次蘑菇，它让我觉得自己重达800磅。你应该再试一次。我觉得你应该再试一次。
And I know you're prone to paranoia and I know that we'd make you talk to your TV. And sleep with your eyes open. With your eye or make you sleep with your eyes open. Right. Sean, Sean once talked to his TV, but, but the other thing. So you think I should try it? I think you should try it. So give it a try for sure.
我知道你容易多疑，我知道大麻会让你跟你的电视机说话。然后睁着眼睛睡觉。用你的眼，或者让你睁着眼睛睡觉。对。肖恩，肖恩曾经跟他的电视机说话，但是，还有另外一件事。所以你觉得我应该试试？我觉得你应该试试。所以一定要去尝试一下。
So give it a try for sure. What I think you should do is you and Scotty should empty the pool. Okay. And then just do Shrooms. And then get in the bottom. So you're safe. You're in the pool. Okay.
所以一定要去尝试一下。我觉得你应该做的是，你和斯科蒂把泳池的水放掉。好吧。然后直接嗑蘑菇。然后坐到池底。这样你们就是安全的。你们在泳池里。好吧。
Okay. God, this sounds like a plan. I'm writing it down. Wait. So Seth, you know, you, you really do have a thousand things going on all the time. It feels like, and I love that about you. You know, you talked earlier about your ambition and your drive and, and, but like, do you ever, is there, is there a master plan or like a bigger thing?
好吧。天哪，听起来是个计划。我记下来了。等等。所以塞斯，你知道的，你身上确实无时无刻不在发生着一千件不同的事情。感觉是这样的，我非常喜欢你这一点。你知道的，你之前谈到了你的野心和动力，但是——但是，你有没有，有没有什么总体规划或者更大的目标？
Like do you want to open like a big studio or like, or do you like what you're doing? You're like your lane you're in. It's good just to go from project to project, right? When I'm stoned. Act. Do you ever acted stoned? Oh, yes. Exclusively for the last decade and a half.
比如你想开一个大制片厂之类的，或者你喜欢你现在做的事？你喜欢你现在所处的赛道。从一个项目跳到另一个项目挺好的，对吧？当我嗑嗨的时候。表演。你演戏时嗑过嗨吗？哦，是的。过去十五年里绝对都是嗑嗨了去演的。
I would say. Yeah. I love it. Wait, wait. Is that tough for remembering dialogue when you're hired now? You're just so that muscle is pretty strong. I'm just always like, there's no, I don't have two gears at this point. It's like, when people say, do you wake and bake?
我会这么说。对。我太喜欢了。等等，等等。你现在被雇佣时，嗑嗨了会不会很难记住台词？你那个肌肉已经练得很强壮了。我总是这样，在这个阶段我已经没有两个档次之分了。就像，当人们说，你早上醒来就抽吗？
Do you say, what's the alternative? Like, yeah. Yeah. I generally, yeah. I, yeah. Well, tell us a little bit. I know an American pickle. Yeah.
你会说，难道还有别的选择吗？就像。对。我通常，对。我，对。好吧，跟我们讲讲吧。我知道《美国泡菜》（An American Pickle）。对。
Because I read a little bit about it. It's a great idea. It's an HBO Max. A Jewish immigrant comes to America in the 20s and falls in a vat of pickle juice, gets brined for a hundred years and returns to modern day. Is that right? Yes. I play exactly that.
因为我读过一点相关的介绍。这是个很棒的主意。它是HBO Max上的节目。一个犹太移民在20世纪20年代来到美国，掉进了一大缸泡菜汁里，被腌制了一百年，然后回到了现代。是这样吗？是的。我演的就是这个。
It starts in the old country. It's a similar, it starts similarly to how most Jewish people's stories started. Like filler on the roof. Yeah. Like Eastern Europe and the Cossacks come and try to kill Herschel Greenbaum and his, his wife, and they come to America and he gets a job in a pickle factory. After his wife gets pregnant, trying to support her. And then he falls in a vat of pickles and is brined for 100 years and then is found.
故事从老家开始。它跟大多数犹太人的故事有着相似的开端。就像屋顶上的提琴手。对。比如东欧和哥萨克人来袭，试图杀死Herschel Greenbaum和他的妻子，他们来到美国，他在一家泡菜工厂找到了一份工作。在他妻子怀孕后，为了养家糊口。然后他掉进了一缸泡菜里，被腌了一百年，然后被发现了。
He's discovered and he's, he has that. He smells great. Yep. He smells good and he's not aged today and his only living relative is his great grandson who's a app developer in Williamsburg and they're the same age. Can I read for that part? I play that part also. God damn it.
他被发现了，他有那种感觉。他闻起来很香。没错。他闻起来很好，而且他今天没有变老，他唯一的活着的亲戚是在威廉斯堡做应用程序开发的曾孙，而且他们俩同岁。我能试读那部分吗？我也演那个角色。该死的。
Did you write it? No. Simon Rich wrote it. Oh, he's a smart guy. Very smart guy. Yeah. I met him. Got a smart dad too.
是你写的吗？不是。西蒙·里奇（Simon Rich）写的。哦，他是个聪明人。非常聪明的人。对。我见过他。有个聪明的爸爸。
Smart dad too. Yeah. He's from, of smartness. But yeah, I met him when I, the first time I hosted SNL, he wrote my monologue and I was like, this guy's really a genius. And yeah, and this is based on like a short story he wrote for the New Yorker quite like maybe six or seven or eight years ago at this point and we've been, it's all, it was a hard movie to, to write.
有个聪明的爸爸。对。他浑身上下都透着聪明劲儿。但是，是的，我第一次主持《周六夜现场》（SNL）时遇到了他，他写了我的开场独白，当时我就觉得，这家伙真的是个天才。而且，是的，这是根据他在《纽约客》上大约六、七、八年前写的一篇短篇小说改编的，我们一直在——这是一部很难编写的电影。
It's super strange and getting the tone right took a long time. Is it a comedy or? It's like a dramedy. I think it has like a being John Malkovich-ish kind of tone of the movies we've made is probably closer to like, like the disaster artist or 50-50 kind of like. Did you and Evan directed? No. Brandon Trost directed it who has been our cinematographer for many, many years and shot,
它超级奇怪，要把基调拿捏准花了很长时间。这是一部喜剧吗？这是一部悲喜剧。我觉得它有一种像《成为约翰·马尔科维奇》那种基调，跟我们拍过的电影相比，可能更接近于《灾难艺术家》或《抗癌岁月》（50/50）那种类型。你和埃文（Evan）导演的吗？不是。布兰登·特罗斯特（Brandon Trost）导演的，他多年来一直是我们的摄影师，拍摄了
shot almost all the movies we've made as a company. And did you say this is for HBO Max? HBO. We made it for Sony originally and then it very quickly became clear that it was not a movie that Sony should release probably. And so they, we were already kind of trying to shop it around to other places and then HBO Max came into existence. Do you care at all about whether something is in the theaters or at home?
我们公司制作的几乎所有的电影。你刚才说这是为HBO Max拍的吗？HBO。我们最初是为索尼（Sony）拍的，然后很快就很明显，这可能不是一部索尼应该发行的电影。所以他们——我们当时已经在考虑把它推销给其他地方了，然后HBO Max诞生了。你在乎某部作品是在电影院上映还是在家里播放吗？
I do in general, do like to have our movies in theaters and, and I do prefer it and I do think that like, you know, that is what my brain is geared towards. Right. I mean, I think I like this, which it sounds like it's got some real, some cultural ambitions. You know, like hard to, hard to market, right? For sure. Very hard to market in, for theaters and in, and honestly, like it is also a relief in some ways because like it is, it is one less box to take, you know, as far as someone who
总的来说我在乎，我确实喜欢我们的电影能在电影院上映，而且我更倾向于此，我也觉得，你知道的，这就是我大脑的运作方向。对吧。我的意思是，我觉得我喜欢这个，听起来它带有一些真正的文化野心。你知道的，这很难推广，对吧？肯定的。要在电影院推广非常难，说实话，这也算是一种解脱，因为在某种程度上，这少了一个需要打勾的方框，你知道的，对于一个
likes to appear successful in the world. Like I, no one will ever necessarily know, you know, and that is always like when we're releasing movies for theaters in a good way, like you have more opportunities for success because, you know, you could get bad reviews, but do well. You could get good reviews, but do bad. You could get good reviews, but do good or you get bad reviews and do bad. But when you're on a streaming service, you, you don't have one of those things. You either basically either get good reviews or bad reviews and that is how you were culturally
喜欢在世人面前显得成功的人来说。就像，没人会强求一定要知道，你知道的，从某种意义上说，当我们在电影院发行电影时，在某种好的方面，你有更多获得成功的机会，因为，你知道的，你可能会得到糟糕的评论，但票房很好。你可能会得到好评，但票房很差。你可能会得到好评，票房也很好，或者你得到差评，票房也差。但当你在流媒体服务上播放时，你没有了其中的某一种东西。你基本上要么得到好评，要么得到差评，这就是你在世界上被文化认可的方式，
viewed in the world and, and you can pretend it's a big hit. Exactly. And then that doesn't really matter as long as, is, you know, there are lots of things can get bad reviews, but are still seen as a success because people watch them. I mean, exactly. And in theaters, you get that, but on streaming, that narrative is harder to carve out for yourself, I think. Well, Seth, I want to thank you for coming on because I've always been so impressed with
而且你可以假装这是一部大热作品。完全正确。然后这其实并不重要，只要，你知道的，有很多东西会得到差评，但仍然被视为成功，因为人们看了它们。我的意思是，完全正确。在电影院里，你会得到那种反馈，但在流媒体上，那种叙事很难为你自己雕琢出来，我认为。好吧，塞斯，我想感谢你来参加节目，因为我一直对
you and your brain and glad to do whatever I can to try to dispel that. No, seriously, the way you handle yourself in the business and just you as a human being, I've always, I mean, 16 years old, starting out in, in this business and, and becoming the man you are today. It's incredibly impressive and I've always, I've always admired you. So I'm, I'm a huge fan and thanks for being on. Well, thank you so much. I second that.
因为我读了一些关于它的资料。这真是一个绝妙的主意。它将在HBO Max上星。一个犹太移民在20年代来到美国，掉进了一大缸泡菜汁里，被腌制了一百年后回到了现代。是这样吗？是的。我演的就是这个。
I want to hang out with you more. I third that I echo what Sean says, man, it's, you've done such awesome stuff. So, so much hilarious stuff over the years. Thank you. It's really, it's really awesome to watch and thanks for coming and being and doing this. We're, we're just getting going on this, but I guess we don't know what we're doing at all.
我想多和你在一起。我完全赞同肖恩的话，老兄，你做过太多棒极了的事情。这些年来有太多搞笑的内容了。谢谢你。看这些真的太棒了，谢谢你能来并参与这个节目。我们才刚刚开始，不过我想我们根本不知道自己在做什么。
Good. You're killing it. So, but thank you. Well, I appreciate it. Thanks for coming, Seth. Thank you for having me. I really appreciate it. All right, pal.
他被发现了，他有那个。他闻起来棒极了。没错。他闻起来很香，而且一点都没老，他唯一的在世亲人是他的曾孙，一个在威廉斯堡的应用程序开发者，而且他们俩同岁。我能试读那个角色吗？我也演那个角色。操。
I'm sorry. See you, pal. All right. That, that's a, that's a nice fellow that Seth, I mean, look, he's Canadian, so you know he's going to be nice. That's right. All Canadians are. I didn't get an all Canadian with him because I knew that Bateman would get all like, Oh
对不起。再见，老兄。好吧。那，那是，那是个好人，我说的是塞斯，听着，他是加拿大人，所以你知道他肯定很好。没。所有加拿大人都这样。我没有在他身上看到纯正的加拿大人特质，因为我知道贝特曼会表现得像，哦
fucking you Canadians. Yeah. No. Well, that's two of us, but I, he's, he's another one of those, those people we've had on this show that I just, I'd like to be friends with. Yeah, for sure. This is, that's what I'm going to use this podcast for is just sort of just audition a bunch of people to widen out my, my friend circle because you guys are it.
你们这些该死的加拿大人。是啊。不。好吧，我们这有两个，不过我，他，他是那种我们在这档节目中接待过的、我想和他做朋友的人。是的，当然。这就是我要用这个播客做的事情，就是挑选一堆人来扩大我的朋友圈，因为你们就是这样的人。
You guys are it. I'd like more than two. You know, it is kind of astonishing what one person can accomplish. I mean, it's all goes like to, to kids. If you know what you want to do in your passion about something early on, the odds go up so much that you'll become successful at it. Isn't it true? Wait a second.
你们就是这样。我希望有不止两个。你知道，一个人能取得的成就确实有点惊人。我的意思是，这一切都归结为孩子。如果你在很早的时候就知道自己想做什么并且对某事充满热情，那么你成功的几率就会大大增加。难道不是吗？等一下。
Wait a second. That was to the kids? No, as, as children, like as kids, I thought you were, I thought you were saying kids, if you're listening, parents leave the room, go get a drink of water. That's okay too. The earlier you know, and he found out, I mean, he knew what he wanted to do at, you know, 12 years old. And he has stayed at the top of his field and he is, he's not just picking up the phone
等一下。那是对孩子们说的吗？不，我是说像小时候那样，我以为你是在说，如果孩子们在听的话，家长们离开房间去喝杯水吧。这也行。越早知道越好，他发现了——我是说，他从12岁就知道自己想做什么了。而且他一直保持在行业的顶尖水平，他不仅仅是在随便接个电话
and, and, and, and managing offers. He's creating stuff and it's, it's pretty admirable that he stayed this successful this long and, and he's more successful this year than he was last year and the year before that and the year before that and it's, it's pretty cool. Yeah. Are you less depressed today? Yeah. Why?
还有，还有，还有，还有管理报价。他在创作内容，而且，而且他能保持这么长时间的巨大成功，这真的很令人钦佩，而且他今年的成就比去年、前年以及更早之前都还要成功，这真的很酷。是的。你今天没那么沮丧了吗？是的。为什么？
Yeah. Wait. Why was I depressed yesterday? You didn't know. Yeah. No, I think I just slept weird, maybe. Yeah. Yeah.
是的。等等。我昨天为什么会抑郁？你不知道。对。不，我想我可能是睡姿不对。对。对。
I slept with my eyes closed. Wow. Oh, Sean. Did you hear that? Yeah. I gotta try that. Try it. Have you guys, do you guys nap?
我闭着眼睛睡的。哇。噢，肖恩。你听到那个了吗？是的。我得试试那个。试试吧。你们大家，你们平时会午睡吗？
Do you really do? I try not to. I, I, I do. Actually, you know what? I think maybe I did. Maybe I took a little nap yesterday. That was it. Yeah.
你真的这么做吗？我尽量不去。我……我……我其实做了。你知道吗？我想我大概做过。也许我昨天小睡了一会儿。就是这样。是的。
And you, you hit that, you hit that wallet about three 30 or four o'clock. I think it's a lack of testosterone too, Will. Well, I was going to say, I always nap, like when I was making, when I was doing my show on Netflix a couple of years ago, I built in that at lunch, I would have food like, you know, I can hammer food five minutes to hammer it down. What is the talk show version of the story? And then I go and I'd fall and I'd go to sleep and this show often puts people to sleep. But you beat me to that one.
还有你，你大概在三点半或四点的时候就会开始犯困。我觉得这也是缺乏睾酮的表现，威尔。嗯，我正想说，我总是会小睡一会儿，比如几年前我在Netflix制作节目的时候，我特意在午餐时间安排了休息，我会吃点东西——你知道的，我可以在五分钟内把食物狼吞虎咽地吃完。脱口秀版本的的故事是怎样的？然后我去睡觉，而这个节目经常让人想睡觉。不过你倒是抢先了一步。
But I would, I would build in cause I had to take a nap in the middle of the day in order to, to do the second half of the day. And then you, and then you get the base camp PA going, yeah, first team, we're ready. Yeah. First team. Yeah. The first time I started doing Broadway and are you guys still there? Nope.
但我会，我会把时间安排好，因为我必须在中午小睡一会儿，才能熬过下半天。然后你，然后你就会听到大本营的助理导演在喊，对，第一组，我们准备好了。对。第一组。对。我第一次演百老汇的时候，你们还在吗？不在。
I would take a nap on a two show day because, you know, it's like a three, there was three hour shows. And I was like, when we first started, I took a nap and I'd wake up like a half hour before the show started and they'd be like, Sean, you ready? Yeah. I'm ready. I'm ready to do this. Like there's no way, there's no way I could sing.
在一天有两场演出的时候我会小睡一会儿，因为你知道，每场演出大约有三个小时。刚开始的时候，我会睡个午觉，然后在演出开始前半小时醒来，他们会问，肖恩，你准备好了吗？是的，我准备好了。我准备好开始干了。就像根本不可能，我绝对不可能唱得动。
And so I had to like scream, I had to get my voice up way high. It was, it was a lot of anxiety. Will, you taught me about lunchtime naps for on camera stuff. You got, you got a, Barry Sonofil taught you to, to nap sitting up so that you don't get puffy eyes. Is that right? So I do. When I nap, I nap with a bunch of pillows so that I'm up and I was doing that RV with
所以我不得不大声尖叫，我必须把声音提得很高。这真的，真的让人很焦虑。威尔，你教过我关于出镜时的午间小睡。你，你——巴里·索南菲尔德教过你，坐着小睡以免眼睛浮肿。是这样的吗？是的，我就是这样。当我小睡时，我会用一堆枕头把自己垫高，我在那辆房车里时也是这样
Barry Sonofil and Barry said to me, I came back once after lunch and he goes, you were napping. And I go, what do you mean? I was napping. He goes, you know, I can see it in your face. I was like, what? And you're like, no, Barry. I just eat a lot of sodium.
巴里·索诺菲尔和巴里对我说，有一次我吃完午饭回来，他说，你在打盹。我说，你什么意思？我在打盹。他说，你知道的，我从你脸上能看出来。我当时想，什么？然后你就像是，不，巴里。我只是摄入了太多钠。
Can I get a bounce card? You can just Hollywood that. I'll Hollywood it myself. I'll just hold this right under the frame. Yeah. Yeah. Isn't that, isn't that tough? And now you sleep standing up like a horse.
我能用个反光板吗？你可以用好莱坞式的方法处理。我自己来处理。我就把这个放在镜头底下。对。对。这不是、这不是很勉强吗？现在你像马一样站着睡觉了。
Now I sleep like a horse. So Sean sleeps with his eyes open and I sleep standing up. Do horses sleep standing up or is that just a urban myth? Oh, hey, welcome to first grade. Hi, I'm Jason. Do horses eat standing up? And then I got a question about the earth and what it's round and what, tell me about the horses.
我现在睡得像匹马。所以肖恩睁着眼睛睡觉，我站着睡。马是站着睡觉的吗，还是这只是个都市传说？哦，嘿，欢迎来到一年级。嗨，我是杰森。马是站着吃东西的吗？然后我得到了一个关于地球的问题，它为什么是圆的之类的，跟我讲讲马的事吧。
Sean. Sure. Uh, I'm not sure about horses actually. Oh, interesting. Will. A cow? So just officially, none of us know whether horses sleep standing up or laying down. Or how about a cow?
肖恩：当然。呃，其实我不太确定马是怎么样的。哦，真有趣。威尔：牛呢？所以严格来说，我们谁也不知道马到底是站着睡还是躺着睡。那牛呢？
Does a cow sleep? Stop Googling. Well, I can see you're Googling. That's what cow tipping is. You know what? How dare you? Or you unwrapping another candy bar. Um, no, they, they actually, they doze when they're standing, but they, for REM, you know,
奶牛会睡觉吗？别用谷歌搜索了。好吧，我看得出来你在用谷歌搜索。这就是推倒牛的意义所在。你知道吗？你怎么敢？或者你又在拆另一块糖果。嗯，不，它们，它们其实，站着的时候会打瞌睡，但要做快速眼动睡眠，你知道的，
for REM sleep, they, um, when they're listening to REM or REM sleep or this podcast, they do it lying down to protect themselves horses, you know, instead doze while standing, you know, oh God, look at him reading the computer like, what did you put into the search window? You know, a special system of tendons and ligaments that enables a horse to lock the major joints and its legs is like, how I'd say it, I know you're trying so hard to make it conversational, but it's so not. We're so dumb. What should we call this podcast?
对于快速眼动睡眠，他们，嗯，当他们听快速眼动或快速眼动睡眠或这个播客时，他们躺着是为了保护自己，马，你知道的，相反会站着打盹，你知道的，哦天哪，看他看着电脑，就像，你在搜索窗口里输入了什么？你知道的，马的一种由肌腱和韧带组成的特殊系统，使马能够锁住腿部的各大关节，就像，我怎么说呢，我知道你一直在努力让它显得很自然，但一点也不。我们太笨了。我们该给这个播客起个什么名字呢？
If we're three dumb guys, what should we, if we're not smart, like dumb asses, you're less, less, you're less smart. You're less. Oh, what about that? Let's see if that's taken. Okay guys, listen. Okay. Super fun.
如果我们是三个笨蛋，我们该怎么办，如果我们不聪明，像个蠢货，你就会变得更不聪明，更不聪明。哦，那个怎么样？看看那个有没有被占用。好了，伙计们，听着。好吧。超级有趣。
Bye. Oh, you did it. Bye. I had to beat you to it. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
再见。哦，你成功了。再见。我不得不抢在你前面。真聪明。少一点。聪明。少一点。
Smart. Less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。少一些。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。